Who do you look up to?
I definitely look up to people
who are being very good mentors in my career,
in different companies,
in previous experiences.
So, today, like I did in the past,
always people that were very truthful to their principles,
people who were very willing to teach,
to give ideas,
that were, really,
I think people who really understood
that being a good manager
is not about being able to develop good work,
but it's about developing good resources.
So, I think one of the biggest achievements for a manager
is not so much reaching your goals
in terms of objectives and budgets,
but really the ability to develop a good team.
To develop resources is something that is invaluable.
Nowadays, talents are something difficult to find
and difficult to retain.
And so, if you have a manager
that is highly successful in this role,
I think you have a person
who is really valuable to an organization.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.